Prof: Good morning.
As you can see,
the title of today's lecture is
"Lifestyles of the Rich and
Famous: Houses and Villas at
Pompeii."
We spoke last time about the
public architecture of Pompeii,
about the forum,
about the temples,
about the basilica,
about the baths,
and also about shops,
and tombs as well.
But today we're going to turn
to the residential architecture
of Pompeii;
residential architecture that
is extremely important,
not only for what it tells us
about Pompeii,
but what it also tells us about
domestic architecture in the
first centuries B.C.
and the first century A.D.,
because there is no place where
the houses are better preserved
than at Pompeii.
So it tells us again,
not just about the city itself,
but also about residential
architecture in Rome,
where we have very few
examples, and elsewhere in the
Roman world.
I want to begin with the image
that you see now on the screen,
which is a building--and we're
talking about the one at the
left,
front left--a building that is
on one of Pompeii's main
thoroughfares,
the Via dell'Abbondanza,
the Street of Abundance.
And the building in question is
relatively well preserved,
and what is significant about
it for us right now is the fact
that it is two-storied,
as you can see here.
What we'll see in the course of
today's presentation is that
most of the buildings,
most of the houses,
in early Pompeii,
are single-story dwellings,
but here we see one that is
two-storied.
And this two-storied dwelling
actually dates fairly late in
the history of residential
architecture in Pompeii.
It dates sometime between the
earthquake of 62 and the
eruption of Vesuvius of 79;
so between 62 and 79 A.D.
And we see that it has two
stories, in this instance.
A story down below that may
have been--
that says has entranceways,
might even have been opened up
as a shop,
and then a second story that is
very interesting indeed.
And it has what we call
cenaculae,
c-e-n-a-c-u-l-a-e,
which are second-story dining
rooms that have open panoramic
windows,
these windows,
as you can see,
through columns.
So an interesting nod to
Hellenization once again,
this idea of incorporating
Greek elements into Roman
architecture --
elements that again are under-
that come into Roman
architecture through the
influence of earlier Greek
architecture,
and views out through those
columns.
So two important points:
one, that these have two
stories,
and that adding a second story
to a Roman building,
or a Pompeian building in this
instance,
doesn't occur until between the
earthquake and the eruption of
Vesuvius;
and secondarily,
this idea of the picture
window.
And we've talked about the
importance for the Romans of
vista and panorama,
and they're doing it here.
They're opening up that second
floor so that you can sit in one
of these dining rooms and then
have a very nice view out
through the columns of the
street and the street life
below.
Now this building,
on the Via dell'Abbondanza,
lies at the end of the
development of Pompeian domestic
architecture.
And so what I'm going to do is
take us back to the beginning
and trace Pompeian domestic
architecture from the Samnite
period up through the eruption
of Vesuvius.
With regard to the earliest
houses at Pompeii,
these were done during again
the Samnite period,
the fourth and third centuries
B.C.
Keep in mind that the Samnites
were an Italic tribe,
that is, indigenous to Italy
from way back when--
I had mentioned to you that
Pompeii was founded already in
the eighth century B.C.
And these Italic tribes built
houses,
obviously, in which they lived
already in the fourth and third
--
substantial houses -- in which
they lived already in the fourth
and third centuries B.C.
I want to begin our
conversation about domestic
architecture in Pompeii,
and by extension in Rome
itself, with the so-called
Domus Italica.
What was the Domus
Italica?
The Domus Italica was an
ideal Roman house plan,
and we know quite a bit about
it because of the writings of
Vitruvius.
Vitruvius -- not to be confused
with Vesuvius --
Vitruvius was an architectural
theoretician who was writing in
the age of Augustus,
Augustus being Rome's first
emperor.
And Vitruvius left a great deal
of writings about all kinds of
architecture,
including domestic
and he talks in detail about
the Domus Italica or what
he considered the ideal Roman
house,
and he describes all of its
parts.
And through his writings we can
explore together what the ideal
Roman house was,
and what you're going to find
very interesting,
I believe, is the fact that the
actual houses at Pompeii
conform,
or the earliest houses,
conform very closely to this
ideal plan.
Let's run through it together,
both in plan and in restored
view.
Again I'm going to need to go
over a lot of terminology here,
but I guarantee you I'm going
to repeat it enough today that
it will be indelibly marked on
your minds and you won't even
have to--
I don't think you'll even have
to study this,
when the time comes,
because you're going to know
these parts of the houses so
well after we go through them
today.
Here you see the plan of the
typical Domus Italica.
You can see at number 1 is the
entrance into the house.
The entrance to the house was
called the fauces,
f-a-u-c-e-s;
the fauces or the throat
of the house.
Sometimes the fauces had
before it a vestibule,
called a vestibulum--and
all of these words are on the
Monument List for you--
a vestibulum,
which was a place right before
the beginning of the
fauces,
underneath the eaves of the
house, where you could actually
stand,
get in from the rain in case it
was raining outside,
while you waited for the door
to be opened.
But in these very early
Domus Italica houses,
we don't tend to see the
vestibulum.
So think it away for the
moment, just the fauces
or throat of the house.
Then on either side of the
fauces there are two
rooms,
which are called cells or
cellae: cella in the singular
and cellae,
c-e-l-l-a-e in the plural.
These can be treated in a
number of different ways.
They can either be closed off
from the street and used as
interior rooms for the house,
extra bedrooms or living
spaces, or they can be,
as you see them in this ideal
plan,
opened up to the street.
When they are opened up to the
street they take on the role of
shops or tabernae,
t-a-b-e-r-n-a-e,
shops or tabernae.
And those shops could be either
used by those who owned the
house, to make additional money,
or they could be leased out to
others for their shops.
You see the fauces leads
into the most important room of
a Roman house,
the so-called atrium,
the famous atrium of the Roman
house,
a-t-r-i-u-m.
The atrium was the audience
hall of the house.
And it's important to mention
from the outset that Roman
houses had a very different role
in Roman society than houses do
for us today.
We tend to think of our houses
today in large parts as
retreats,
as places we can get away from
it all --
get away from work,
get away from schoolwork and so
on,
and escape.
Although we do enjoy obviously
having friends and family visit
us there, we tend to think of it
as a place of retreat.
This was not true in Roman
times, when the house was also a
place to do some very serious
business.
The man of the house,
the head of the household,
the paterfamilias,
often greeted clients in the
atrium of the house,
and when he was away on
business, or away at war,
his wife, the
materfamilias,
would stand in for him and she
would conduct business in the
atrium.
So considered a very public
part of the house,
a place where you wanted it to
look its best because you were
going to be greeting important
visitors there,
to do business.
So the atrium is located here.
You can see this rectangular
pool in the center of the
atrium.
That is the
impluvium--and you have
that on the Monument List--
the impluvium of the
house, which is a pool in which
they collected rain water for
daily use.
How did they collect that rain
water?
Because there was an opening in
the ceiling, also rectangular in
shape.
That's called a
compluvium,
and the compluvium had
surrounding it a slanted roof to
encourage the water obviously to
slide in through the
compluvium and land in
the impluvium down below.
Around the atrium and also
around the impluvium,
at 4 here, are the bedrooms of
the house,
the cubiculum,
in the singular,
and cubicula,
in the plural:
the cubicula or bedrooms
of the house.
And you can see that each one
of them opens up off the atrium.
They are very small in size,
smaller than any other rooms in
the house, and they were
literally just a place to sleep.
They were very small,
mostly very dark.
Some of them had slit windows.
I'll show you one of those
later.
Many of them didn't have any
windows, they were literally
just sleeping spaces.
Over here, at 5,
we see the wings or the
alae, a-l-a-e--the wings
or the alae,
ala in the
singular--alae of the
house.
The wings of the house were a
very important place from the
point of view of family
tradition and religious practice
and so on.
It was the place where the
Romans kept the shrines of their
ancestors.
They had wooden shrines--they
were usually made out of wood--
with doors, and they kept
inside those the busts and
portraits of their ancestors,
and they would take those out,
they would open those shrines
up and take those out on special
occasions,
usually anniversaries marking
the anniversary of the death of
the deceased.
And they had an interesting
practice in which the member of
the family who most closely
resembled the deceased in size
and general appearance would put
on that mask and participate in
a kind of parade in honor of the
dead.
So they kept those in those
shrines, in the wings or the
alae of the house.
Here at 6 on axis--and we know
how much the Romans liked
axiality as well as symmetry--
we see the room over here,
at 6, is on axis with the
fauces and the atrium.
This room is called the
tablinum,
t-a-b-l-i-n-u-m,
the tablinum,
which started as the master
bedroom of the house,
the most important bedroom,
much larger than the
cubicula,
but over time it became a place
where the family archives were
kept.
And beyond that--and we'll see
it happening pretty early
actually today--
it becomes almost a kind of
passageway between the atrium
and the area that lay beyond
here.
At 7 we see also a fairly large
room,
the dining room or
triclinium,
and you can see in this case,
in the ideal Roman house,
it opens off the atrium;
so easy to get to from the
atrium.
And then at the back,
number 8, for one of these
ideal Roman houses,
the hortus,
h-o-r-t-u-s,
or the garden of the house,
which was obviously open to the
sky.
If you look at the restored
view, you can see how these
earliest houses really had a
very enclosed feeling.
They were quite stark and
geometrically ordered,
with very few openings.
You can see,
in this case,
this one opening as an
entranceway into the
fauces,
as well as into two shops,
as you can see here.
And then, of course,
the compluvium,
a hole in the ceiling,
and then the hortus is
open to the sky.
But, other than that,
there are no windows
whatsoever.
It's a very enclosed structure.
And we're going to see that
although that's the case in the
beginning that changes over
time;
we'll see a very important and
interesting evolution.
Now another point that I want
to make from the start is just
as in temple architecture,
and we've traced the
development of early Roman
temple architecture,
where we saw the Romans
ultimately using--
combining an Etruscan plan with
a Greek elevation.
We're going to see something
actually quite similar happening
in the development of Pompeian
and Roman domestic architecture.
We're going to see that
Etruscan, earlier Etruscan
monuments, had an impact.
And I show you a plan of an
Etruscan tomb over here--
we've looked at this before--an
Etruscan tomb over here,
just to show you that the
general arrangement of that
tomb,
with an entranceway here,
with two rooms over here,
kind of like the
tabernae that we looked
at,
or the cells that we looked at
just before.
A big space over here,
not unlike the atrium.
The idea of axiality:
entering into it,
then this large space,
then another space which
mirrors the tablinum or
is like the tablinum of
the Roman house,
and then other rooms on either
side.
So this whole idea of this
progression of one space,
an axial progression of one
space to another space to
another space that's on the same
axial focus;
very important,
and I think those who were
building these fairly early on,
the Samnites and so on,
were clearly looking at
Etruscan examples.
And it shows us,
very early on also,
that in the minds of the Romans
there was a very close
association between the houses
of the living and the houses of
the dead.
Because if you look at the
inside of this Etruscan
tomb--and I mention it;
I'm not holding you responsible
for it, but I mention it to you
underneath the Domus
Italica on the Monument
List.
This is the Tomb of the Shields
and Seats in Cerveteri of the
sixth century B.C.
And if you look at it,
you can see that inside the
tomb--
it's all carved from the rock,
from the tufa rock--
you can see that it looks very
much like what you'd expect a
house to look like,
with beds.
And notice the detail.
They've even provided--it's all
done in stone,
the tufa stone -- but you see
they've even provided stone
pillows here,
not very comfortable,
but it gives you the sense of
what a house would've been like.
And we know that beds in houses
looked very much these.
Over here a throne,
with a nice footstool,
as you can see.
And then if you look very
carefully, also indicated in
stone, the rafters,
the beams done in stone.
And then the moldings around
the door and around the shields,
which is the reason this is
called the shields and the seats
obviously is because it has
seats and it has shields on the
wall.
So I just wanted to make the
point,
because it'll turn up a number
of times in the course of the
semester,
the close association in the
minds of the Romans between
houses of the living and houses
of the dead,
and also that important point
that the early Samnite builders
are looking at Etruscan
prototypes.
I want to show you now the way
in which actual Pompeian houses
conform very closely--
the early ones at least,
of the fourth and third
centuries B.C.--
conform very closely to this
Domus Italica ideal plan.
I want to begin with the
so-called House of the Surgeon
in Pompeii, which dates to the
third century B.C.
And it's called the House of
the Surgeon because of all the
surgical instruments that were
found in the house,
and I show you the array of
them now on the screen.
This should be of considerable
interest, to especially--and I
know there are a number of you
in here -- students whose major
is biology.
And I want to mention also that
you might be surprised to hear--
but maybe not,
Yale has such amazing
collections--
that the Medical School has a
collection of surgical
instruments that goes way back,
and it goes way back to ancient
Rome.
You can actually see ancient
Roman surgical instruments in
that collection that we have
here at Yale,
not perhaps as many as this,
but an interesting selection,
and those of you who are in
that field might at one point
want to take advantage of that
and get to see them firsthand.
So this house got its name from
this cache of surgical
instruments that were found
inside.
That probably gives us some
sense of the profession of at
least one of the people who was
living here.
I show you the plan of the
House of the Surgeon,
and you'll see a version on
your Monument List that actually
has the rooms designated there,
which I don't have here.
So that will be helpful to you
as you--I wanted you to have
that version so that you,
when you're studying,
you have that before you.
And in any exam,
by the way, even if I show
something slightly different in
class, I will show you only what
is on your Monument List in the
exam.
So those are the ones that you
should study and remember.
But you'll see the plan is
exactly the same.
It just doesn't have the labels
here.
So we can see that it conforms,
the House of the Surgeon,
third century B.C.,
to the ideal Domus
Italica plan.
You enter here;
you enter into the
fauces or throat of the
house.
There are two cells,
one on either side.
It's very clear in plan that
this cell is closed to the
outside and opens only off the
atrium, so used by the family
for their own purposes.
This one is open to the street,
clearly used as a shop,
either by this family,
or they've leased it out to
somebody else.
The atrium is on axis with the
fauces.
We can see that the atrium has
a pool, a rectangular pool,
or impluvium;
and there would've been a
compluvium up above.
On either side the
cubicula or bedrooms of
the house, opening off the
atrium.
Over here the wings or
alae of the house,
for the ancestral shrines.
Over here, again,
a dining room,
a triclinium,
that opens off the atrium.
Up here we think probably a
portico, one column or two,
but that might belong to a
later renovation,
and I'll explain why in a
moment.
And then in the back a somewhat
irregularly shaped hortus
or garden.
But I think you can see from
this example how closely these
actual houses track the Domus
Italica described by
Vitruvius.
Another example of one of these
early Roman houses that conforms
to the Domus Italica type
is the so-called House of
Sallust in Pompeii that dates to
the third century B.C.
This is another house that has
the Domus Italica as its
core.
But, just like most of the
houses in Pompeii--
you'll remember how when the
Romans took over Pompeii in 80,
or made Pompeii a Roman colony,
they tossed the Samnites out of
their homes,
they took them over,
and of course once they took
them over,
they renovated them.
So there's quite a bit of
renovation that takes place to
some of these early Samnite
houses.
In this case the House of
Sallust seems to be an example
of that.
But we still see the original
core of the Domus
Italica.
The entrance over here into the
fauces of the house;
I'll say something about that
in a moment.
The atrium on axis with that,
with the impluvium.
The cubicula over here.
The alae or wings here.
The tablinum of the
house over here.
In this case you can see that
the triclinium opens up
off toward the hortus
instead.
This family wanted to provide
views of the hortus
rather than the atrium,
from the dining hall.
Now what's particularly
interesting, and may belong to
the renovation,
are the shops that are opening
up off the street.
Because you can tell in plan
exactly how this shop was used.
Anyone volunteer to say,
based on the plan?
What kind of a shop was this?
Student:  Fast-food
restaurant.
Prof: A fast-food store.
Yes it's a fast-food shop,
a thermopolium,
because we can see the counter
and we can see the recesses in
plan.
So this family either had,
or let its space out,
for one of these
thermopolia,
for one of these fast-food
stands in the front of their
house.
So two examples,
the House of the Surgeon and
the House of Sallust,
that conform closely,
third century B.C.,
to the original Domus
Italica plan.
In the second century B.C.
we see something happen in
house design,
quite extraordinary,
and that is linked to the same
kind of development we saw in
temple architecture,
and that is yes,
they've been looking at the
Etruscan type of plan,
they've been conforming to that
to a certain extent.
All of a sudden in the second
century they get the bug to make
their houses look more Greek,
and they begin to incorporate
elements that they take from
earlier Greek architecture,
and the result is quite
extraordinary.
I'm showing you here an example
of an ideal plan of what we call
the Hellenized Domus,
the domus that has been
Hellenized,
that has been given Greek--it
has been enhanced with Greek
elements.
And let's run through the plan
again, of the so-called
Hellenized domus type.
You can see that the core is
the same as the Domus
Italica.
You enter over here.
Here we can see in plan the
incorporation of the
vestibulum,
this vestibule that is located
right in front of,
or at the beginning of the
fauces,
the purpose of which--you can
see it right here--
the purpose of which,
you kind of entered into the
house.
The roof of the house protects
you in case the weather is not
good,
but you still have to stand in
that vestibule until you're
allowed into the fauces
and the rest of the house.
So we see here the
vestibulum,
the fauces,
the two cells,
cellae, one on either side,
in this case they are not
opened up as shops.
The atrium here,
with its impluvium,
to catch rain water.
At 4, we have the usual
cubicula,
or bedrooms.
At 5, we have the usual
alae or wings.
And then 6, the tablinum
on axis with 7,
the triclinium opening
off the atrium.
So once again the core of the
original Domus Italica,
very much intact in the
Hellenized domus.
But look what's happened up
here.
What's happened up here is at
number 8,
under the influence of Greek
architecture,
under the influence of what's
happening in temple
architecture,
they incorporate columns into
the interior of the house,
and they place their garden
here.
It's a garden court,
with columns,
which technically is called a
peristyle, p-e-r-i-s-t-y-l-e.
And it is comparable to what we
see in temple architecture when
we saw the architects giving
some of the temples--the
peripteral colonnade;
do you remember the colonnade
that goes all the way around and
is freestanding,
under the influence of Greek
architecture?
It's the same sort of thing
here, except it's on the inside
of the building.
So this peristyle court cum
garden, located right here.
And then on either side,
additional bedrooms or
cubicula;
these were probably very
desirable, to have a bedroom
that opened, had a nice view out
over your garden.
And then back here two
additional triclinia,
two additional dining rooms,
to take advantage of the
beautiful views that one could
get,
if one could see it -- probably
not terribly much through these
narrow doorways,
but at least opening up onto
the peristyle court.
One second.
We see up here the restored
view, showing the same,
the entranceway.
And look here,
you can even see columns added
in the front to announce,
from the very start,
that this is a house that is
owned by a very cultured
individual,
who knows his Greek,
and knows his Greek culture,
and knows to incorporate these
Greek elements into his house.
Then we see the
compluvium.
We see the peristyle from above;
you can see,
open to the sky with columns,
but still very stark,
very plain on the outside.
No windows to speak of,
very much an enclosed space.
Student:  I was just
wondering--I always like looking
around--where the food
preparation would take place?
Prof: Some of these
houses did have kitchens,
and I'll show you an example in
a moment.
Probably more of them did than
we're sure of.
It's just a question of what
remains, in terms of being able
to determine that.
But we certainly have examples
of that.
So they did seem to have
kitchens.
So now I want to show you some
examples of houses that conform
to the Hellenized domus
type, this being the first one.
It's one of the most famous
houses in Pompeii,
and if you're going there
anytime soon and are making a
list of must-sees,
this is one of those must-sees,
in Pompeii,
the House of the Vettii.
We think it belongs,
although we're not absolutely
sure, to the Vettius brothers,
to the Vettius brothers in
Pompeii.
And it dates,
as the Monument List indicates,
to the second century B.C.
and later.
Looking at this plan you can
see the way in which it conforms
to the Hellenized domus
type.
Once again it has the core,
it has the Domus Italica
core.
The entranceway over here,
with the fauces;
the cells on either side,
in this case used as rooms
internal to the house,
they do not open off the street
as shops;
the atrium here,
with the impluvium;
a smaller number of
cubicula on either side;
alae over here.
Look what has happened to the
tablinum.
The tablinum is gone
essentially.
All it consists of is a couple
of pilasters that are located
right here--
and I'll show them to you in a
moment because it's
well-preserved pilasters here.
So the tablinum has
essentially disappeared.
It's become a kind of
passageway from the core of the
house into the garden.
And it is a peristyle garden,
surrounded by columns,
as you can see.
And you can see how important
that peristyle garden has
become.
This family has decided to
decrease their other space in
order to have this stupendously
large garden here.
And they have also put a very
large dining hall,
triclinium up here,
that opens off the peristyle,
and it has a much bigger
opening so that they could
clearly dine and get views of
this garden,
this peristyle garden,
of which they were obviously
incredibly proud.
So some major changes there.
Now this particular house--oh I
did want to say though,
despite those changes,
the house is still very
enclosed and very plain and
stark from the outside.
This is a restored view of what
we believe the outside looked
like.
So geometrically ordered,
cubic, as you can see.
Just one entranceway,
possibly a few small windows,
possibly not.
And then you can see the
compluvium and the
peristyle court.
But otherwise very much
enclosed, like the earlier
Domus Italica;
not much change with regard to
how the exterior of the building
is treated.
This again is one of the
reasons everyone flocks to this
house is it's very well
preserved.
There's been some restoration
work,
of course, but really this is
one of those must-sees,
because it really gives you as
good a sense as anything of what
these houses looked like in
antiquity.
We have obviously entered
into--we've come through the
fauces.
We are standing in the atrium.
We can see the pool or
impluvium here.
We can see the
compluvium,
very well preserved,
up above.
I think it's probably the best
preserved compluvium that
we have, or close to it.
And you can see that there were
little antefixes added in
terracotta and stuff,
as decoration,
up at the top.
As we're standing here we look
back through what was once the
tablinum,
and now is basically a point of
transition,
a passageway from the atrium to
the most important part of the
house,
from the point of view of these
patrons,
the garden.
So you're looking through.
You see these great piers on
either side, that are all that's
left of the tablinum.
You look through that and you
see the garden.
The garden has its columns
surrounding it.
The walls are painted,
of that garden,
all a very lively and wonderful
interior.
And what also becomes very
clear in looking at this
particular view is something
that we've already discussed,
and that is the importance in
the minds of the Romans of vista
or panorama,
of great views that you can see
from one part of a building to
another.
Remember the Sanctuary of
Jupiter Anxur at Terracina and
all of those wonderful lateral
and axial entrances and exits,
where there were all kinds of
interesting light effects.
We see the same sort of thing
here.
The idea is to pass from a
particularly well-lighted area
outside into a darker area,
the fauces.
Then a little bit more light
added to the system through the
compluvium,
and then a whole host of light,
that you can see in the
distance,
through the open--because of
the open peristyle.
So dark, light,
dark, light -- this progression
of space, this progression of
light through the structure a
very typical Roman thing to do.
The other thing,
of course, is this emphasis on
axiality, this movement through
a structure in a very axial way.
The garden here,
as it looks today.
It would've been,
of course, even more beautiful
in antiquity,
when it would've been in better
shape.
But nonetheless,
this gives you--it's a bit
overgrown now and so on--
but it gives you some sense of
what it would've looked like,
with the greenery in the
garden, surrounded by the
columns,
with garden furniture,
little fountains,
little marble fountains and the
like,
and with the walls--the
paintings are not in very good
shape today,
but imagine them more vibrant.
And I'm going to show you
examples of that on Thursday and
next week,
of some of the paintings that
are in better condition and how
vibrant this would've been with
those paintings.
Look also at the columns
because you can see--
we'll see that some of these
columns are made out of stone,
some of them are made out of
those tiles,
that look like bricks,
that I've shown you before.
But in all cases they were
stuccoed over white.
Why were they stuccoed over
white?
To make them look like Greek
marble.
So once again,
this Hellenization of Roman
domestic architecture,
this attempt to make these
things look as Greek as
possible.
You asked about the kitchen.
Well this is our best preserved
kitchen, from Pompeii.
It's really quite amazing.
There's a stove,
and the pots and pans that were
clearly still sitting on the
stove at the time this
particular family had to flee
from Vesuvius.
And I neglected to show you,
but you can look at the
Monument List for this plan,
where the rooms are marked.
You will see the kitchen marked
on that plan.
And you will also see what's
called the Women's Quarters,
marked on that plan,
which was probably where some
of the slaves who were owned by
this particular family,
the Vettius brothers,
lived, in that area.
Another example of a house that
conforms,
a Pompeian house that conforms
to the Hellenized domus
type is the one that you now see
on the screen.
It's a plan of the House of the
Silver Wedding,
in Pompeii.
We believe it was remodeled in
the first century B.C.,
although it's controversial.
It might have been remodeled a
bit later in the first century
A.D.
It's an interesting structure.
It got its name,
the House of the Silver
Wedding,
because there was a lot of
fanfare in the late nineteenth
century--
I think it was precisely
1893--when the king and queen of
Italy came to visit this
particular house,
and it became their favorite.
And so the Silver Wedding is
actually a reference to them and
to their marriage,
and so on and so forth.
It's a wonderful house,
and I think you can see how it
conforms.
Again, it has a core that is
very much the Domus
Italica core,
but it is another example of
one of these houses that has
been remodeled because of the
owner's interest in Hellenizing
that house.
We enter here through the
fauces.
There are cells on either side,
opening off the fauces.
It's an unusual arrangement.
Then over here the atrium with
the impluvium;
the cubicula on either
side;
the alae or wings of the
house;
a dining room over here;
two peristyle courts,
one in the back,
a smaller one,
and then a huge peristyle court
over here on the left-hand side.
So for this family one was not
enough, they wanted double the
garden space,
and they've allotted a lot of
space in this house to those
gardens.
Then, most interesting of all I
think about this house,
and the reason I chose it to
show to you,
is that we are starting to see
the Hellenization of the atrium
as well.
Because look what's happened to
the atrium.
They have placed four columns
around the impluvium,
in the atrium.
So it wasn't enough to have
these two large peristyles,
they wanted columns everywhere,
and they placed these four
around the impluvium.
An atrium that has four columns
in it is technically called--and
I put it on the Monument List
for you--a tetrastyle atrium;
this is a tetrastyle atrium.
Even that wasn't enough.
Look at that room in the upper
left.
That room in the upper left is
a banqueting hall,
an additional dining space,
but a special dining space,
that you can see opens up very
nicely off the smaller peristyle
of the house.
The opening is fairly wide,
so it probably would've had
some wonderful views of the
peristyle garden.
And look, there are four
columns in there as well.
And this particular banqueting
hall,
its technical name--it's got a
kind of a funny name that I
don't think you'll forget called
an oecus,
o-e-c-u-s;
and it's even more amusing in
the plural, because the plural
is o-e-c-i, oeci.
So this is an oecus,
among oeci,
an oecus up there.
And you can see that it's an
oecus that has four
columns in it;
so we call it a tetrastyle
oecus.
All right, so now that we've
had an opportunity to look at
the plan of the House of the
Silver Wedding,
I want to give you a sense of
what the building looks like
today.
It's not as well preserved as
the House of the Vettii,
but we can get a very good
sense of what it was like in
antiquity.
And the oecus,
which in some respects is the
most important room in the
house, from our standpoint,
is very well preserved.
We're looking here at a view.
We're standing again in the
beginning of the atrium,
looking through the atrium.
We see the impluvium of
the house -- a lot of moss and
some--it's overgrown today.
But nonetheless you can see it
there, as well as the
compluvium above.
What's most important to us is
you can see that this is indeed
a tetrastyle atrium,
with four columns that are
surrounding the
impluvium,
those columns supporting the
ceiling,
and of course the
compluvium above.
Also interesting is the way in
which the columns are treated.
You can see that they have been
fluted and then stuccoed over.
Do you remember the temple at
Cori,
that we looked at,
where we talked about the fact
that--
the Temple of Hercules at Cori
-- we talked about the fact that
the columns were fluted part of
the way,
and then down below those
flutes were covered over with
stucco and the stucco was
painted.
We see the same thing here.
And if you look very,
very closely,
you can even see the remains of
the red paint,
the red paint that decorated
the lower part of these columns.
So some interesting
correspondences there in terms
of building practice.
You can also see here,
as we saw in the House of the
Vettii,
this wonderful vista from the
atrium of the house,
through what remains of the
tablinum,
into the garden of the house,
the peristyle garden of the
house,
which from the patron's point
of view was one of the most
important,
if not the most important part,
of the house.
This is the oecus of the
House of the Silver Wedding,
and you can see it is extremely
well preserved,
and you can also see how very
interesting it is,
in all kinds of ways.
It is a tetrastyle
oecus--again,
a banqueting hall--tetrastyle
oecus,
with four columns.
Those columns are stuccoed and
painted over.
The paint is very well
preserved.
It's a reddish,
purplish color,
probably meant to conjure up
porphyry, p-o-r-p-h-y-r-y,
porphyry, which comes only from
Egypt.
It's only quarried in Egypt,
very expensive to bring it that
great distance,
all the way to Pompeii.
And, of course,
this isn't porphyry,
it's just a painted column.
But the whole idea of this,
from the patrons' point of
view,
was to look like he and she
were very well-heeled,
that they could afford to
bring--they're trying to make
the illusion that they could
afford to bring this expensive
stone,
from very far away,
to use in their house here.
Look also at the fact that
there's a barrel vault.
This is actually a wooden
vault, rather than a concrete
vault here in this room.
But very nicely done,
and the walls are extensively
painted.
They are weathered today,
but they give you a very good
sense of what would have been
the original appearance of this
room.
And, as I mentioned,
we'll talk in detail about
Roman wall painting,
especially because,
as you can see,
it does depict architecture.
We'll begin that conversation
on Thursday and continue into
next week.
I want to turn now to what is
surely the most important
surviving house at the city of
Pompeii, and this is the famous
House of the Faun.
If you're in Pompeii and you
only have time to see two
houses, you go to the House of
the Vettii and the House of the
Faun.
The House of the Faun,
as you can see from your
Monument List,
dates to the second century
B.C., for the most part,
and we see a view,
part of Pompeii over here,
with a series of houses marked
in yellow.
And the reason that I show this
to you is because the House of
the Faun is particularly large.
You can see from this plan that
it takes up in fact the entire
block,
an entire block of the city of
Pompeii,
and it is much larger than some
of the others.
For example,
look at the House of the Vettii
over here.
It's twice, if not larger,
than that: twice the size of
the House of the Vettii,
if not even more than that.
So it's a very large house.
Clearly no expense was spared,
either in accumulating the
property, and also in enhancing
the dcor of the house.
If we look at a plan of the
House of the Faun,
we will see,
without question,
that it corresponds and it
follows the Hellenized
domus type.
We enter over here.
We see it has a
vestibulum;
a fauces;
two cellae, one on either side;
an atrium with an
impluvium;
the cubicula here on
either side;
the wings or the alae.
It does have a tablinum,
you see it over here,
and then it has two peristyle
courts,
with columns encircling them,
a smaller one and then a very
large one in the back.
Note also, while this is on the
screen, that there is a very
interesting room that is located
over here.
It's a rectangular room.
It has a couple of columns on
bases and pilasters,
one on either side.
It opens right off the
peristyle court,
and on the floor of that space,
which we call the Alexander
exedra,
e-x-e-d-r-a,
after Alexander the Great,
because on the floor of that
was the most famous mosaic that
we have surviving from
antiquity,
that represents Alexander the
Great,
and I'll show you that
momentarily.
First let me show you what the
house looks like from the
outside.
It's well preserved.
It doesn't have its ceiling the
way the House of the Vettii
does, but otherwise it's pretty
well preserved.
We're looking down the street
on which it finds itself.
You see the polygonal masonry
blocks.
You see the sidewalks here as
well, and how modern they look.
You see the stepping stones.
And over here the faade
of the House of the Faun.
You can see the entranceway,
and you can see that the
entranceway has on either side a
pilaster, a pilaster with a
Corinthian capital above.
And that's very important,
because it's announcing to us,
as did that ideal Hellenized
domus that I showed you
before,
it's announcing to us that this
is a patron,
this is an owner of this
particular house who has
leanings toward things Greek and
wants us to know that,
even before we have entered
into the house.
You go into the house and stand
in the vestibule.
You will see that there is
still quite a bit of decoration
preserved.
The walls are painted with
blocks, what look like blocks of
stone: an illusion.
This is an example of First
Style wall painting;
we're going to talk about that
on Thursday.
And then up here a shrine is
still preserved,
a shrine that probably held
statues or statuettes of some of
the household gods,
the revered gods for this
family.
This is an excellent view
because it shows us again how
entering this house you would
stand in the vestibule;
you'd go from there into the
fauces,
then into the atrium,
then into the peristyle that
lay beyond --
the first smaller one and then
the larger one after that.
But it shows us again the point
that I've made so many times
already,
just in this first part of the
semester,
and that is this Roman interest
in vista or panorama.
They've set up a view from the
moment in which you enter the
house,
a sequence of experiences from
light to dark to light to dark,
but also a sequence of visual
experiences that make entering
this house and walking through
this house an extraordinary
experience,
one that they have helped
enhance.
And you can also see again the
capitals here.
Here's a view of the atrium as
it looks today.
We are standing in front of the
impluvium.
In that impluvium is a
statuette in bronze of the
Dancing Faun,
from which this house gets its
name.
The one that you see there now
is a copy and the original is in
the Archaeological Museum in
Naples.
This view also shows you the
way in which you had the series
of visual experiences,
from the fauces to the
atrium,
and ultimately toward the
peristyle with its wonderful
forest of columns done
la Grecque,
in the Greek style.
Here's another interesting view.
We're still in the atrium.
You can see the Dancing Faun
right here.
We're looking at the side wall;
if we're facing the Faun,
this is the wall to the left.
This is very helpful because it
shows us exactly what the
cubicula that opened off
the atrium would've looked like.
You can see that they were very
dark.
Some of them had these tiny
slit windows,
or perhaps slightly larger slit
windows.
But for the most part they were
very dark -- again meant only as
a place to sleep at night and to
be used for no other purpose
than that.
You can also see from this view
that this is a rubble wall that
has been stuccoed over,
and that reliefs,
painted different colors,
have been placed on that wall.
This is an example of so-called
First Style Roman wall painting,
and we'll go into what that
was, define what that was,
and discuss it in more detail
on Thursday.
This is a wonderful restored
view of what the House of the
Faun would've looked like when
all of its First Style Roman
wall painting was intact,
showing what it would've looked
like to stand in the atrium and
look back through what survived
of the tablinum,
with these very large pilasters
again,
announcing the Greek leanings
of this particular patron.
And then the view toward the
peristyle, where you would also
see the columns that looked like
they were very much in the Greek
style.
So here's clearly a person who
not only is building his home to
correspond to the latest in
domestic architecture,
namely the Hellenized
domus type,
but who just wants to make that
point over and over and over
again: that he's cultivated,
that he knows things Greek,
and that he has the funds to be
able to incorporate those into
his house.
And indeed First Style wall
painting, as we'll find out when
we discuss it,
is also a style that is based
on Greek prototypes.
So another example of the Greek
elements in this building.
What room do you think this is?
Oh I didn't show you this on
the plan; I neglected to.
But you can look at your
Monument List.
When you look at the plan,
you'll see that this house had
more than one atrium;
it had two atria.
And this is one of them.
It's a tetrastyle atrium,
because you can see there are
four columns,
one around each corner of the
impluvium.
So a house with two peristyles;
a house with two
atriums,
and even one of the
atriums has four columns,
as you can see here.
And this one is also very
useful for the fact--
one of you asked me a question,
when we were looking at the
Basilica of Pompeii,
about why the columns looked
the way they did--
I think it was you--and I
mentioned that they were pieced,
and here you can see that very
well,
these drums placed one on top
of another.
So that you can see over time
how easy it would be for some of
those to fall off or become
dismantled,
and for us to be left with the
sort of thing that we're left
with when we look at what
remains in the Basilica of
Pompeii.
Here's a view obviously of one
of the peristyles.
Here you also see something
interesting in terms of building
technique.
The columns in Pompeii tend to
be either of local stone,
a local tufa,
or made of these tiles that
look like bricks,
but then in either case
stuccoed over,
white, fluted,
to make them look,
once again,
like they are marble columns:
the illusion that they are
marble columns,
even though they are not,
to underscore their Greekness.
This is a view of that exedra,
that Alexander exedra that I
mentioned to you before,
that opens off the first
peristyle,
with two columns on bases here.
Note the red at the bottom,
white at the top.
Two pilasters painted red,
as you can see.
And you can see the tourists
standing there,
gazing down.
They're gazing down at a copy.
And this copy,
by the way, for a very long
time,
for as long as I remember going
there,
except for this last time I was
there was nothing there,
and I think most people had no
realization that this amazing
mosaic originally was on the
floor.
But they have a put a copy--the
mosaic is now in the Naples
Archaeological Museum,
long ago moved there.
But they finally put a copy
down on the floor,
so that--of the mosaic that was
there--
so that people who visit the
House of the Faun realize,
oh, this is where the Alexander
Mosaic was located,
which is particularly
important, because this is a
view of the mosaic,
this extraordinary mosaic of
Alexander the Great,
that's now in the Naples
Archaeological Museum.
And, of course,
you can see that they display
it there as if it were a panel
picture, hanging on the wall.
But that is not how it was
displayed, or meant to be
displayed, in the House of the
Faun.
It was a floor pavement in the
House of the Faun.
But look how nicely,
at least in the museum,
they have recreated the
ambience by putting the columns
and the pilasters--
they tried to recreate the
sense of the exedra,
just as it is in the house.
It's just that they put the
mosaic in the wrong place;
it should be on the floor.
Nonetheless,
you can see it's an
extraordinary work of art.
I'm not going to go into it in
great detail,
but I did want to expose you to
it because it is so important
and so magnificent,
and I also want to make
absolutely sure that you don't
miss,
when you go to the Pompeii
area, you do not miss going to
the Archaeological Museum in
Naples.
It's an amazing museum,
one of the greatest of all the
museums in Italy,
and it has of course--almost
all the great stuff that comes
from Pompeii is at that museum
today.
So it's another one of those
asterisked, must-sees.
You look at it here.
It represents the battle
between Alexander and the
Persian King Darius,
d-a-r-i-u-s,
at the famous Battle of Issus,
i-s-s-u-s, and at that battle
Alexander was victorious,
and you see it here.
And one of the reasons that
it's so important for our
understanding of the House of
the Faun is that we believe that
this mosaic was a copy of an
earlier lost Greek painting,
a Greek painting of this same
scene,
of Alexander and Darius,
done in around 300 B.C.
by a Greek painter,
that was copied for this house
in mosaic, sometime in the
second century B.C.
So it's another example of this
patron,
of this owner of the house,
who is so besotted with Greek
art that he wants to have as
much of it around him as he
possibly can,
and he clearly has the assets
that enable him to commission a
mosaicist to make this amazing
painting .
Now there are a lot of people
who talk about this mosaic,
and they say,
"Well, you know,
it's such a pale reflection of
what the painting would've been,
and it's a typical derivative,
Roman art.
They had to look at Greek art
and derive from it.
They couldn't come up with
anything on their own."
But I would maintain that's
absolutely untrue,
and I would also maintain that
to do this kind of work in
mosaic,
rather than paint,
is much more difficult.
This is a true tour de force,
to be able to create this kind
of active battle scene,
with collapsing horses and with
spears in the sky foreshortened,
and foreshortened weapons down
here.
This is an amazing thing to do
in mosaic,
when you think of all of these
individual tesserae,
these small stones,
multicolored stones,
that had to be brought
together, placed in mortar,
to create this amazing tableau.
To me it seems like it is a
much, much greater feat to have
to achieve that,
and to achieve it so well in
mosaic than in paint.
Just quickly a couple of
details.
Here's the one of Alexander
himself on his horse.
It's an incredible
characterization of the great
Hellenistic general and king,
and you see him on his favorite
horse, Bucephalus here;
and I think it's a wonderful
characterization by this
particular,
very talented mosaicist and his
workshop,
to capture the relationship of
man and horse.
If you look at not only the
eyes, but also at the hair,
the hair of Alexander tousled,
flowing in the wind,
the mane of the horse,
so closely allied with one
another.
The artist has really very
effectively captured that again,
even just using these very
small pieces of stone,
which you can see very well
here.
Look at the way the shadows are
cast, even by that stone.
It's incredible.
Here's the other detail that
I'm going to show you of Darius,
in his chariot.
As you can see,
he's looking toward Alexander,
he's mesmerized by the great
Hellenistic king,
but he's at the same time
afraid.
And he's beating a retreat,
because you can see that his
driver has turned the chariot
around.
He's whipping the horse and
he's heading in the other
direction, away from Alexander,
as is this figure here.
We see his horse from the rear,
a real tour de force,
depicting a horse.
But he too is looking at
Alexander, quite afraid,
and his horse is also turning
to go off into the distance.
So capturing this very dramatic
moment.
And to me the most wonderful
detail is this one,
that you see down here,
which is a view of one of the
fallen Persians;
the shield is falling over on
him, but the shield is polished
to such a shine that he can see
the reflection of his own face.
I have a detail to show you of
this.
He can see the reflection--you
see it here--of his own face in
that shield.
And this view is particularly
good.
I took this one very close up,
so that you could see the
individual stones.
You don't--from a distance they
blend, but when you go up close
you can really see,
oh yeah, that's a mosaic.
And it's really an
extraordinary work of art.
A very quick question because--
Student:  How big are
the stones?
Prof: They're very
small, they're very small,
and the reason for that is in
large part so that they will
blend ultimately,
and from a distance it will
have the feel of a painting.
Certainly when it's on the
wall, probably less so when you
stood and looked at it,
in its original location,
because you'd be looking down
on it and you'd be closer to it
than here.
But it's an amazing work.
And again remember that
although the original painting,
done by the Greek painter,
was probably,
did hang on a wall,
this one was meant as a floor
mosaic in this house --
but again a testament to the
Greek leanings of this
particular patron.
Now I also wanted to show
you--that's not the only mosaic
in Pompeii.
It's the greatest,
by far, and it's without
question--
and I think everyone who
studies this stuff would agree
with me,
that it's the finest surviving
mosaic in the history of ancient
Greek and Roman art.
But there are plenty of other
mosaics preserved,
including at Pompeii,
and I want to show you just
one.
It's mentioned underneath the
Alexander mosaic,
on your Monument List,
because it's so beloved;
it's even more beloved by most
tourists to the site than the
Alexander mosaic,
which after all you can't see
on the site,
you have to see it in Naples,
at least the original.
But this is the so-called Cave
Canem Mosaic,
and it belongs to the House of
the Tragic Poet,
a house that was put up between
62 and 79 A.D.
And you see what's meant to be
a very ferocious dog with his
teeth bared.
This one is done much more
simply, in only three colors;
mainly black and
white--tesserae or small
stones;
t-e-s-s-e-r-a-e,
that's what these small stones
are called, the
tesserae--black and
white, basically black on white.
But you can see that there's
one touch of red,
the collar of the dog.
And the dog is chained,
as you can see,
just like that poor plaster
cast of the dog that we saw last
time, he's chained.
But he's meant to look very
ferocious.
He's baring his teeth.
And the whole point,
Cave Canem, beware of dog,
is for you to be warned of the
fact that if you dare step any
further than that
vestibulum,
and try to get into this house
or try to steal anything or
whatever,
this dog will attack.
So it's the same kind of--it's
like a security alarm system
actually for antiquity.
And I bet you can tell me where
in the house this mosaic was
located.
Student:  The
fauces.
Prof: In the
vestibulum or the
fauces of the house.
Yes, probably the
vestibulum actually,
indeed the vestibulum of
the house,
so that even before you got in
as far as the fauces you
were warned that you'd better
beware of the dog.
And this thing,
you will see this--any of you
who've been to Pompeii know this
and can attest that I'm right--
every single souvenir stand,
anywhere within any numbers of
yards of Pompeii,
is selling the Cave Canem on
everything you can possibly
imagine: the mugs,
the T-shirts,
the hotplates,
the whatever,
the tote bags.
You can get the Cave Canem in
every shape, size and
possibility.
And I have one of those myself,
only one, only a hotplate,
but that's it.
I did it like everybody else at
one point, years ago.
I want to show you briefly a
couple of other houses,
just to make a few small
points, well,
important points,
an important point or two about
each of them.
The first one is the House of
Menander, in Pompeii,
which dates to the second
century B.C.
and later.
You see it in plan here.
The House of Menander,
like everything else we've seen
in the latter part of this
lecture, is a Hellenized
domus.
You can tell that because of
the peristyle here.
In other respects it's very
similar to everything we've
seen: the usual fauces,
atrium, cubiculum,
tablinum system,
the large peristyle up here,
and some dining spaces opening
off that peristyle.
What makes this particular
house interesting,
and the reason that I show it
to you,
is it's a good illustration of
what happens when over time you
remodel,
and also over time,
when other property becomes
available nearby.
And we can tell from this plan
that what happened here is that
the core of the house was added
to,
as property on either side,
additional property,
became available,
and this owner purchased that
property and added it.
And the plan becomes much more
irregular obviously,
because of that.
An addition over here,
an addition over here;
some of that sense of axiality
and symmetry is lost when you
start to add to either side
horizontally.
But there are lots of houses
like this,
and it's one of the things one
needs to keep in mind as one
visits the city and as one looks
at each of these incredible
structures.
Just very quickly,
with regard to the house,
just so you have a sense of
what it looks like today.
It's named the House of
Menander because of this
painting of the poet who sits on
a chair over there,
on one of the walls of the
house.
Part of the peristyle is
actually quite well preserved,
as is the atrium.
We're standing in the atrium,
as you can obviously see,
with the impluvium,
looking back toward the garden.
This is interesting because you
can see again the
cubicula opening off
either side,
but also because of the
incorporation,
just as in the House of the
Faun, of columns elsewhere than
just in the peristyle.
These in that transition place
between the atrium and the
garden,
the so-called tablinum
space,
these very large columns,
stuccoed over,
fluted, and you can see in this
case,
not painted red at the bottom
but a kind of bright yellow to
match the colors of the wall.
So again this incorporation of
Greek elements into houses like
this one.
This is also a good view.
It's a very well-preserved
house.
We're back in the atrium again.
You can see the way in which
the cubicula,
the small cubicula open
off that.
You can see some of the
paintings.
And here's the entranceway,
through the fauces,
and you can see in this
particular case a small shrine
that's located in the corner --
the purpose of that,
for the household to display
the household gods.
This is another interesting
house that I just want to treat
fleetingly.
It's the so-called House of
Pansa in Pompeii,
and it dates to the second
century B.C.
And it's a very large house,
as you can see,
like all the other Hellenized
domuses, because we see that it
has a peristyle with columns
here.
Like all the others it has
everything that we've seen:
the vestibulum;
the fauces;
the atrium;
the cubicula;
the wings or alae;
the tablinum,
a dining room;
and a bevy of shops down here.
In fact more shops than we have
seen be the case in most of the
houses we've looked at,
at least five,
if not six shops down here,
which gives us something of a
clue to something that might be
going on in this house.
If we go back to the peristyle
and we take a look at that,
we see that there's a pool in
between the columns.
And you might speculate,
"Oh how nice;
a nice pleasant pool.
You could sit around,
you could dip your hands or
your feet into that pool;
a nice pleasurable spot to
enjoy."
Well actually it wasn't that at
all.
We think now that it was
probably a pool that held fish,
and fish--not fish,
just attractive fish that one
could admire,
but actually fish that were
sold in one of the shops in
front.
One of the reasons we believe
that is a scholar by the name of
Wilhelmina Jashemski,
whose specialty is gardens of
Pompeii,
has spent her whole scholarly
career--
and it was well worth it
because she's come up with some
extraordinary things--
on studying the root marks of
the gardens in Pompeii,
and she's been able to
demonstrate,
through studying those and
working with experts on that
sort of thing,
just what was grown in these
gardens.
And you find that some of them
were pleasure gardens with
beautiful flowers,
and some of them were produce
gardens.
And this one was a produce
garden, so that there would've
been vegetables and fruits and
so on,
that were gardened here and
then they were sold in the shops
that were located at the front.
So here we see a wonderful
example of the way in which
these houses could even be used
by some owners as a means of
income for them and for their
families,
and that was surely the case
with the House of Pansa.
It also has a very
well-preserved peristyle.
We can see the columns here
around that pool that was used
to hold the fish that were sold
in one of the shops.
The columns are extremely well
preserved,
including some of the capitals,
Ionic capitals,
as you can see here,
and the fluting,
and then the plain,
stuccoed over at the bottom,
with the paint--you can see in
this case,
remains of the red paint that
would've decorated the bottom
part of those columns.
Another very interesting house,
and one that's important for us
because it marks a later
development in Roman house
architecture in Pompeii,
is the House of Marcus Loreius
Tiburtinus.
Remember Tibur was the ancient
word for Tivoli,
and so it's likely that
Tiburtinus in fact came from
Tivoli,
moved to Pompeii,
and built this large house
sometime between the earthquake
and the eruption of Vesuvius,
so 62 to 79 A.D.
Like the House of the Faun,
it took up an entire city
block.
But you can see that the owner
has made a different decision
than the owner of the House of
the Faun,
because the house itself takes
up very little space,
and most of the space is taken
up by the garden.
We're less sure here whether
this was a pleasurable garden--
there are some indications that
it might have been--
or whether it too was used as a
produce garden.
We don't have all those shops
on the front,
so that seems less likely here.
But you can see it's another
example of the way in which
these houses are becoming not
only more personalized,
but also with much more
emphasis on the garden and on
the dining rooms that are
surrounding that garden;
we see one of those dining
rooms here.
What's particularly interesting
about this house,
and one that helps us round the
circle to where I began at the
beginning of the lecture when I
talked about the fact that it
was between 62 and 79 that the
Pompeians began to build second
stories on their houses.
They began to expand
vertically, and we saw the
cenaculae of the Via
dell'Abbondanza building.
We see the same thing happening
here, that a second story has
been added around the living
quarters.
Now here it was obviously
really needed,
because they weren't giving
much space to the living
quarters, so they had to build
up vertically for those.
And if you look very carefully
at the restored view,
you will see that the windows
of that second story open off
and look out over onto the
compluvium of the atrium.
You see that there,
the compluvium of the
atrium,
and then around it you can see
the second story,
with the windows looking out
over the compluvium of
the house.
Then the rest,
needless to say,
garden.
It's actually pretty well
preserved.
It's fun to wander around.
You see these wonderful
trellises and all kinds of
interesting architectural forms
that are part of this incredible
garden,
in the House of Tiburtinus.
And you even see there this
magnificent grotto,
which leads me to believe that
we're beginning to see something
interesting here,
which is the incorporation of
the sorts of things that you
would tend to see in villas,
not right in the center of a
city, but villas that were
located either outside the city
or along the coast.
And the reason I say that here
is because we can see this
grotto-like effect,
where we have what looks like a
pebbled effect on the back wall:
painted,
two columns,
Corinthian columns,
with a pediment above,
and then these two wonderful
mythological paintings.
This one you probably recognize
as the Myth of Narcissus.
You can see his reflection in
the water;
he's admiring himself in his
reflection down below,
and then Pyramus and Thisbe
over here.
What's important to us is not
which myths, but just that Greek
myths are incorporated into the
scheme here;
so this pretension toward
things Greek.
But most important this
grotto-like element that you
would tend to find in a villa
along the Amalfi Coast or some
such,
rather than in downtown Pompeii.
So we're beginning to see this
interesting merging,
at least for the very
well-to-do, the rich and famous
as we--
the lifestyles of the rich and
famous,
as this lecture is called;
we begin to see that in some of
the houses, especially in the
later period.
The second to last building
that I want to show you is an
extremely important one;
the last one we'll just look at
for a minute or so.
But this one is an extremely
important building.
It is the Villa of the
Mysteries, in Pompeii.
It is indeed a villa.
So it's a nice segue from the
Loreius Tiburtinus House.
What started to happen in
Pompeii,
even though there was quite a
bit of space initially,
as time went on things became
more crowded,
and the really well-to-do began
to move outside the city,
to the suburbs,
so to speak,
right outside the city --
interestingly enough,
right along those same streets
that formed the cemeteries,
of the city.
So we see the villas and the
cemeteries intermixing in a very
natural way.
But this very important villa
was part of that development.
And I want to say--it went
through a couple of phases,
and I want to show you the two
phases here.
Only Phase Two is on your
Monument List,
so I won't hold you responsible
for Phase One,
but I think it's important for
us to look at it together.
Because what we see here is
something very interesting.
Looking at the top,
we see the entrance into the
villa.
We see the peristyle there,
the atrium there,
and the tablinum there.
Now what do you think about
that?
It's very strange.
We've never seen a house or
villa that departed from the
scheme that we talked about
before,
from this movement from the
entranceway,
the fauces,
into the peristyle first,
then into the atrium,
then into the tablinum.
It's a different progression.
We might think to ourselves,
well this must be the whim of
this particular patron,
but Vitruvius tells us
otherwise.
Vitruvius tells us about villa
design,
and he tells us the major
distinction between Roman villas
and Roman houses,
in terms of their plan,
is that in Roman villas you
enter into the peristyle first.
So it shows again the growing
interest in peristyles.
And yet this peristyle,
very, very early indeed,
because it belongs to the first
phase,
which is even before the early
second century B.C.,
which is when the second phase
is dated.
We can also see here a great
podium, and I'll say a bit more
about the podium as we look at
Phase Two.
This is Phase Two of the house,
and this is the one that you
have--the villa--this is the one
that you have on your Monument
List.
The main spaces are labeled
here.
You can see the entranceway;
the fauces;
the peristyle first,
a very large peristyle;
the atrium of the house here;
the tablinum over here.
So this different order
described by Vitruvius.
We can see also that it rests
on a tall podium.
I'll show you what it looks
like in a moment.
It is a podium that looks
exactly like the podia we saw
for the great sanctuaries at
Tivoli and Palestrina.
We see that underneath that
podium,
just as at those -- or Jupiter
Anxur at Terracina,
just as at Terracina -- we see
there's a cryptoporticus
or underground passageway,
underneath that podium.
It is barrel vaulted,
and the concrete is faced with
opus incertum work,
just as we saw it in the
sanctuaries.
Why have this kind of podium
here?
To give the villa an even
grander appearance,
to put it up high on top of a
podium,
and also to help to muffle the
sounds from the street--
remember, this is a major
street, a thoroughfare that's
just left the city and has
become an intercity road--
to muffle the sounds that one
would hear from that,
by raising the villa in a sense
away from them.
The most important point though
that I can make about this
villa,
and something that speaks to
the future,
is the fact that we are
beginning to see--
we've talked about how enclosed
and plain and severe the earlier
exteriors of Roman houses were,
even up through the Hellenized
domus,
except perhaps for the addition
of a pilaster or a column here
and there.
Here we see something entirely
new happening.
We see that the architect has
designed these elements that
project out of the rectangle of
the villa plan,
and are curved;
and you can see one over here,
and most importantly one over
here.
It's like a giant bay window,
with views that can be seen
through that bay window.
So this projecting out into the
viewer's space and so on,
and also into the space of
those who live inside this
building,
offer wonderful panoramas and
vistas of the sea beyond.
The sea was closer to Pompeii
at that point than it actually
is today: beautiful views out
onto the sea,
and in a sense the exterior of
the structure breaking out of
its rectangular bonds to do
something entirely different
from what has come before.
This is a restored view of what
that structure would've looked
like in its second phase,
and I think you can see that
very well here,
resting on this tall podium.
Arcades, just as at the
sanctuaries;
these are blind arcades,
just as we saw there.
Concrete opus
incertum facing.
But look at the difference that
having this bay window has made.
They've opened up the wall.
The windows are very large.
No more slit windows.
Big panoramic windows,
projecting elements,
also with very large windows,
there's hardly any wall there
whatsoever.
The rest is the same.
The compluvium,
the peristyle,
all look like they did in the
Hellenized domus.
But this is a big change and
one that looks forward again to
the future.
This is a view of it as it
looks today: the Villa of the
Mysteries.
You can see the great podium
over here, with its blind
arcades, as well as part of the
house.
And look at how open that house
is.
Now part of this is villas.
There's more of a desire when
you build a villa to open it up,
more so than a house in town.
But it's also an important
development for architecture as
a whole.
This is a view of the peristyle
court.
It's a little different than
any other peristyle court we've
seen,
because you can see they have
embedded the columns into the
wall of the--
there's a wall around;
the columns are embedded into
that, which is a different
motif.
And I thought you'd be amused
to see that the Villa of the
Mysteries is one of those --
and there are several places in
Italy,
many places in Italy,
where people go in particular
to take photos,
after their wedding,
to take photos of themselves:
photo-op places.
And the Villa of the Mysteries
is one of them.
So don't be at all surprised,
if you are there,
especially on a weekend,
if you see a wedding party
taking photos.
And this was one of the more
discreet photos.
You can just imagine the kinds
of poses that people take in
places like this.
I could've shown you all kinds
of very amusing,
very loving photos of the bride
and groom.
But here you just get a sense
of the photographer,
and there were several
photographers the day I took
this,
getting wonderful images of
this bride and groom after the
happy event.
I just want to close,
just very briefly,
with this last house,
or this mosaic fountain from
this last house.
It's the so-called House of the
Large Fountain,
so-called because of this
extraordinary fountain that was
found there and still exists.
Dates to between the earthquake
the eruption of Vesuvius,
62 to 79 A.D.
It's very well preserved.
You see it here on the
right-hand side of the screen.
It shows you that mosaics could
be applied to any kind of
surface by these very talented
artists,
in this case applied to a
curved surface,
as you can see very well here,
once again using multi-colored
tesserae,
as we saw in the Alexander
mosaic.
And you can only imagine how
lovely it was when there was
actually a water display and so
on,
in fact, so lovely that it was
imitated almost exactly for the
Getty Villa in Malibu,
which I show you on the
left-hand side of the screen.
Many of you have probably been
there.
The Getty Villa--it looks like
Disneyland I know,
but it probably gives you a
better sense of what a Roman
villa looked like in antiquity
than anything else,
even that you can see in Rome,
because it's in such pristine
shape.
And it really gives you--it is
based, for any of you who don't
know, it is actually based on a
villa from Herculaneum that was
excavated.
We know it.
It's based very closely on it,
the so-called Villa of the
Papyri,
at Herculaneum,
and then it picks and chooses--
it looks at other things as
well and incorporates them,
as it incorporated this
fountain.
But it probably gives you--it's
in better condition.
You can see that the water
display is actually working,
unlike the one in Pompeii.
So it gives you a very good
sense of what this thing would
have looked like in antiquity.
And just as a look forward,
one of the paper topics for
this course actually is to talk
about the Villa of the Papyri,
in the context,
in part, and being helped by
the reconstruction at the Getty
Museum.
On Thursday we will move on to
Herculaneum.
We will talk about the lives of
the people there,
some of the houses that were
built there between the
earthquake and Vesuvius,
and we will also begin our
conversation about First Style
and Second Style Roman wall
painting.
We'll have a few lectures on
painting,
because it's so important as
the interior decoration of these
homes,
and because,
as we'll see,
it depicts architecture--
and you can get a sense of that
here--
in ways that are very
intriguing and that tell us even
more about buildings than we
already know.
Thanks everybody.
Have a good morning.